und ich könnte rein theoretisch auch mal
eben den nikolaus ich hoffe ich werde es
nicht angegriffen niemals nicht in einer
million jahren auf keinen fall france
klm ist aktiv an jetzt negativ
hallöchen freunde willkommen zu
minecraft freester
sieben ich habe mir freute natürlich wie
der fünf fragen rausgesucht wo ich mir
gedacht habe
die kontrolle ganz gut beantworten und
im gegensatz zur letzten folge habe ich
mir gedacht kommen luca künste dir mal
so ein bisschen lautstärke in minecraft
deswegen habe ich jetzt mal etwas
umgestellt damit wir jetzt hier wieder
die lautstärke mit am start haben und
irgendwie wird das hier zugebaut sich
gerade das liegt einfach daran dass ich
bisher noch nicht alle weiter den ist
tritt meiningen gang runter gebaut damit
direkt die erste kohle
ich bin aber eigentlich auf der suche
nach eisen weil ich mir einen
wassereimer machen wollte und die eisen
rüstung vollenden wollte ich habe in der
letzten folge gesagt dass ich ein wenig
streamen wollte demnächst und da bin ich
derzeit auch immer noch ganz fleißig
daran das ganze gut umzusetzen also ich
bin dabei dass ich mit tricks die diese
eigentlich mache und ein paar wären also
dass ich einfach da so ein paar so dass
man da weißt du dass das auf meiner
seite ist ein paar standardmäßige sachen
dass da mal ein facebook profil verlinkt
oder sowas
solche sachen mich da zurzeit noch an
regeln aber das interessiert dann
natürlich alles gar nicht ich wollte nur
sagen
demnächst kommen die ersten streams
vielleicht habe ich auch zu dem
zeitpunkt wo die folgekosten 1 gemacht
das kann ich jetzt noch nicht guck mal
da ist ein kleiner de oder eine höhle
oder einfach nur was mit reisen die ich
brauche drei eisen und hier sind drei
okay hier sind genau 3 eisen ist hier
und noch was irgendwo hier ist nicht
hier schnittmenge dann gehe ich mal
wieder ertönt wieder zugemacht
das spiel gemacht ich mach das mal
lieber so zu und dann kann ich mich
nämlich hier noch mal eine plattform
kann ich mich nicht es soll natürlich
schon alles ein etwas schönerer runter
grad
dann werden ich möchte eigentlich gar
nicht bin nicht so der sprit mailing fan
jetzt bin ich hier wieder in diesem
scheiss wasserbecken und dann machen wir
das wieder zu infizieren stückchen unter
welcher höhe sind wir denn wir sind auch
würde 42 ist der freude kommt ich sag
mir wie ich habe ja selber auch keinen
bock strippen einigen zu betreiben
deswegen suchen wir uns einfach eine
höhle oder beantwortet auch schon erste
frage und zwar sli schreibt mir findest
du dir gedanken traurig dass leute ganz
allein an weihnachten sind
ich bin die person ich bin ich bin der
ansicht der meinung und so ihr wisst was
ich meine
keiner muss an weihnachten eigentlich
alleine sei es gibt leute die sind
einfach an weihnachten gerne alleine
es gibt aber auch leute die weiß ich
nicht die schilder nirgendwo da so mit
freunden oder so weil die familie flex
weit weg ist oder so also natürlich
extrem die von weiss ich nicht soldaten
oder studenten oder so die irgendwie die
ganze zeit in der in der uni sein müssen
und keine ferien oder so bekommen haben
obwohl er nicht recht selten ist dass
man keine ferien bekommen
aber ich bin auf jeden fall der ansicht
muss alleine sein jeder hat irgendwie
familie oder freunde und die ich weiß
nicht was ich packe dem damaligen hier
neue samen damit stürmer für nicht merkt
dass ich ein feld benutzt habt und ich
mach das sogar hier noch auf das geht
gar nicht weil dieses komische dinge
habe ich da was kaputt mal was kaputt
gemacht ich pflanze das sogar hier alles
nach sondern wie ich bin mit partnern
auch mal eben hier noch die hühner dann
können wir noch ein paar mehr hühner und
staat bekommen also ich finde keiner
muss alleine sein und man sich der
gedanke dass jemand sagt nur ich möchte
weihnachten alleine verbringen denke ich
mir warum das ist das fest des
beisammenseins und sowas und so weiter
und so fort aber ich denke jetzt ist
jedem selbst überlassen wie er
weihnachten verbringt und jetzt
verbringen möchte
und von daher bin ich da komplett
tolerant so ich lege ich mal eben kennen
und danach werde ich mal da hinten hin
laufen genau da wo ich hin zeige und
werd mir diese dunklen bäume holen denke
ich mal
aber vorher mache ich mir noch immer zu
reisen so freunde die brote sind am
konnte den erfolg backen brot erzielt
diese ganzen erfolge hier immer ich
glaube jetzt auf jeden fall mal nach da
hinten und auf dem weg kann ich
eigentlich schon mal die nächste frage
beantworten und zwar fragt mich der
linie lp gab es bei ihren der schule
auch einen nikolaus mal verliebte eine
zombie hat eine richtige rose klassen
und der hier wird jetzt wahrscheinlich
sogar eine rüstung oder nein doch nicht
an eboue zwar ne ich denke mal mit gab
es da ein nikolaus
weiß ich nicht genau was damit meint
also ich denke mal was anderes gab es
bei uns nicht ich hab mein mikro hier
geschlagen
ich denke mal dass er meint das alte das
ist ja richtig gefährlich hier
das sei so nikolaus umgegangen ist und
so kleine nikoläuse verschenkt hat diese
teile die man halt zu essen kann diese
schoko nikoläuse und zwar war das bei wo
sind denn hier wo sind denn hier diese
bäume haben wir gar keinen sprit mehr
oder wo sind denn die ganzen setzlinge
davon
ich glaube einfach käfertreffen eine
ganze setzlinge davon geklaut hat er
sich davon irgendwas genommen oder so
off screen weil das kann ja nicht sein
dass im caps baumhaus einfach das
komplette spruce rot ist und es gibt
einfach kein anderes grußwort mehr ich
weiß dass ich mainz grußwort von da
vorne hatte aber anscheinend ist das
einfach wenn ihr mal schaut kerschbaum
ist komplett aus blues und das ist
natürlich schon ein wenig aussieht wenn
man das macht natürlich nicht
nachvollziehen
nein spaß aber wo sind denn jetzt russo
teile ich brauche auf jeden fall dieses
dunkle haare guck mal schaut mal hier
hier ist echt ganz schön aus wer wohnt
de niro holt den ihrem unternehmen
ok ich kann man nicht hoch genug für die
reise nicht auf jeden fall ein ganz
schönes heusel ii und hier ist hier
zeigt ob das kann nicht sein dass alle
hielten des klimas cruz wurde oder sowas
am start
das ist doch wo ist so kann das denn sei
dieses ganze spruce wird das kann doch
nicht einfach vom vom er was ist das
denn
das kann er nicht einfach vom erdboden
verschluckt sein dieses plus wird wir
müssen das auch mal irgendwo finden oder
so also um auf die frage zurückzukommen
also ich gehe jetzt erstmal so ein
bisschen meinen weg und schob ich
irgendwas bluesport finden diese erfolge
also ein bisschen entdeckungs folge aber
um auf die frage zurückzukommen ja diese
nikolaus diesen schoko nikolaus und zwar
ist heute bei uns in der uni also ich
bin gerade ein bisschen four produzieren
weil ich habe ich letzten folge schon
gesagt
samstag bis dienstag unterwegs bin und
dann erst dann bin ich erst
dienstagabend irgendwann wieder zu hause
wir können jetzt auch mal rein
theoretisch von hier einfach mal schauen
ob wir hier irgendwo grußwort sehen aber
ich sehe es nicht mal die sind doch das
ist der kann ja nicht sein der muss doch
irgendwo jetzt halt nicht meine höhle
wie muss doch irgendwas grußwort sein
das ist doch aber das niveau haben denn
wo hat den kev das heer außer von mir
ich weiß nicht genau ob die höhle hier
ist auch schon erforscht ich weiß nicht
genau wo kämpft das her hat weil ich
seine folgen dich gesehen hat und weil
er denkt ich auch viel of screen gemacht
hat aber also ich weiß nicht ich muss
ein großes wort finden aber ja bei uns
gab es gerade freitag und ich bin am
vorproduzieren und erschwert es einfach
kaputt gegangen hat eine scheiße
jedenfalls kam bei uns auch leute in den
uni hörsaal rainer marten also ja da wir
sechster also sechs hier am samstag da
wieder keine uni haben haben wir gedacht
wir jemand schonmal nicolai sondern
haben wir nico leute bekommen und ich
könnte rein theoretisch auch mal eben
den mikrofonen ich hoffe ich werde nicht
angegriffen wartet moment also die haben
wir von der uni geschenkt bekommen so zu
weihnachten die meinten soja nikolaus
und so bekommt von uns nikolaus klingt
ja ganz logisch aber jetzt so richtig
dass da einer so verkleidet rom gegangen
ist oder so das hatten wir in der
grundschule mal aber auch nicht auf ein
gymnasium an der zwar im studium halt
auch nicht wenn man dafür ja ja wir sind
halt nicht irgendwie mehr so ganz jungen
und deswegen ach ich weiß nicht auf
jeden fall darf bei uns nichts daran
nico leute bekommen ja mal wieder
richtig gas geben ich habe für die
ersten beiden fragen schüler hier zehn
oder acht oder neun minuten gebraucht
oder so um den dreh
jedenfalls fragt mich die angeht zu der
liga also angelika vorrat michael steck
fries waren beginnst du mit dem
weihnachts shopping
ich habe damit schon halb angefangen und
zwar ist es bei uns so dass auch viele
geburtstage im dezember sind und
deswegen habe ich für meine mutter schon
alles fertig einkauft für meine
schwester auch schon für mein vater weiß
ich nicht weil ich nicht weiß was ich
ihm irgendwie schenken kann er meinte
man brauche nichts hast du das immer so
richtig wenn leute meinen ich brauche
nichts mehr man kann irgendwie ich finde
immer was gebrauchen und guck mal hier
hier ist ganz schöner sehe und so weiter
läuft
hier kann man sich echt gut irgendwie
hin bauen oder so aber ich suche einfach
grußwort weil ich jetzt endlich mein
haus fertig stellen möchte aber es gibt
einfach nirgendwo auf dieser welt
fußball hier ist schon wieder
sonnenallee sind echt geile sehen hier
am start
das kann doch nicht sein irgendwo muss
doch cruise wurde am start sein
also zu der frage mit dem weihnachts
shopping new york so halb habe ich schon
damit angefangen aber ich bin mir nicht
sicher was ich will mein vater kaufe
weil er halt meint dass er nicht braucht
und das weil sie nicht irgendwas brauche
und er meint dass ich bin irgendwie weil
wird nicht parat man muss ja etwas
verschenken oder so deswegen ich weiß
nicht was ich ihnen dann dahin zu halten
mal selbst da oben sind keines bruce und
bäume sondern diese birken teile hier
ist halt nichts ich kann nicht mal mehr
sprinten ich kann nicht mehr sprinten
und ich merke schon irgendwie dass die
sonne sich immer mehr dem ende zuneigt
und ich laufe jetzt erst mal wieder nach
hause das kann ja nicht sein
dieses bruce oldfield als muss ich ihnen
ersatz für spruce wird filmen
vielleicht habt ihr da irgendeine idee
oder so dann kann dies ja mal die
kommentare schreiben nächste frage kommt
von michelle missgeburt hattest du mal
ein schlimmes weihnachtserlebnis wenn ja
was war es
spross mit bäume
ein
na ja also ich hatte noch nie so richtig
schlimm ist weil ich sage mal war dass
kaka oder irgendwie so aber ich hab mal
ein jahr nicht das bekommen was ich mir
gewünscht habe
weil es nicht angekommen ist von der
post her weil das über ebay verschickt
wurde und ebay.de mal so eine sache mit
passen ankommen alles mögliche und da
war ich dann extrem traurig und so war
ich nur das bekomme was ich will einfach
nie haben wollte
ich habe irgendwie so allerdings
bekommen irgendwie weiß nicht einmal was
ich bekommen habe
ich hab so ein sandwich toaster oder
sowas in richtung bekommen und so was
alles halt aber das braucht sich halt in
dem alter gar nicht und ich habe mir
eigentlich irgendwie ein gameboy
gewünscht oder sowas und weil sie nicht
dabei ich halt schon extrem traurig aber
ja ich weiss nicht also es gab jetzt
kein weihnachten wo ich echt erscheint
oder doch juli der sucht die schreibt
hashtag fries wann hast du immer am
heiligabend eine geschenke aufgemachten
morgens mittags abends oder heimlich
dumm halter soja oder hast du die
vielleicht gar nicht aufgemacht oder
peinlich oder
wir haben das meistens mal so gemacht
dass wir in die kirche gegangen sind
abends und dann danach abends auch noch
die geschenke ausgepackt haben wir uns
jetzt aber damals auch manchmal so
gemacht dass wir einfach irgendwann
abends die geschenke ausgepackt habe am
nächsten tag ist in die kirche gegangen
sind
das war einmal so ein bisschen
unterschiedlich kommt drauf an wie lust
wir da gerade drauf hatten oder wie wir
das halt zu machen dass auch zu der
sache die ich vor 455 mal angeschnitten
hatte bezüglich der weihnachts tradition
die es bei uns einfach nahezu gar nicht
gibt
was ist halt auch so eine sache dass wir
dazu wir gehen immer die kirche aber die
zeiten sind immer unterschiedlich und
sowas deswegen ja also geschenke
auspacken aber meistens einfach abends
wo dann hol montiert noch ein bisschen
kohle die fragen habe ich jetzt
eigentlich hauptsächlich erstmal durch
ist auch schon das video neigt sich
schon wieder dem ende zu aber ich muss
natürlich noch zurückkommen oder ich
glaub mich einfach hier aus ich meine
das ist nicht wahr wo ich mich irgendwo
in ecke stellen muss oder so damit ich
nicht in der nächsten folge direkt von
stege und und tobi april abgeschmeckt
werden
ich weiß auf jeden fall da hinten ist
dass da ja dahin ist das zuhause ich
habe erst mal genug grußwort ich habe
hier ja fichtenholz ich hab mir nur elf
stücke egal ich glaube das sollte
erstmal reichen ich habe nämlich auch
hier einen setzling und ich denke ich
kann mich auch noch ebenen setzinger
direkt vier stück jedenfalls würde ich
sagen meine lieben freunde mir hat die
folge wieder extrem viel spaß gemacht
weil ich jetzt endlich fichtenholz
gefunden habe und jetzt weiß dass ich in
der nächsten folge die ich auch mit
einem anderen youtuber aufnehmen werde
mein haus endlich fertig stellen kann
ich bin wieder fünf fragen eingegangen
wenn es euch auch gefallen hat würde
mich über eine bewertung freuen schreibt
mir wie immer fragen unter den hashtag
fries auf twitter twitter.com search von
crafter verfolgen wollten der
beschreibung findet ihr alle anderen
mitspieler und dann sehen wir uns in
einem nächsten video von minecraft fries
wieder an dem 8 12